[Music]
the sauna is a centuries-old finnish
tradition
99 of finns sit in a sauna at least once
a week
most homes apartment buildings and even
offices have one
don't live in finland but want to enjoy
the benefits of a home sauna
no sweat
this outdoor sauna is made of premium
canadian red cedar
which is aromatic and resistant to mold
first they measure the wood with a
hydrometer
to ensure the humidity level is below 12
percent
if the wood is too moist it will shrink
after assembly
leaving gaps between the planks
[Music]
once they've determined that the wood is
stable they put the planks through a
molder
the machine's seven different tool heads
smooth the top and bottom surfaces
the machine also carves tongue and
groove edges that will tightly lock one
plank to the next
the assemblers build the barrel shaped
sauna in sections
for the bottom they start with a central
plank that has a tongue on both sides
[Music]
the tongues and grooves fit together to
render the joints water tight
the assemblers continue adding planks
until there are eight on each side of
the central one
they construct the sauna's back wall
using the same technique
once they've joined together the
required number of planks
they lay down a circular template and
secure it with clamps
then they cut around the template with a
[Music]
router
[Music]
to further secure the planks to each
other they drill angled holes through
adjacent ones
and drive in screws they also screw in
three horizontal reinforcement planks
[Music]
using a pattern as a guide they cut out
a window with the router
they screw window moldings around the
opening
they apply an adhesive-backed rubber
insulation strip along the perimeter
this will prevent heat and water from
leaking out between the walls of the
sauna
[Music]
they mount the front and back walls onto
the bottom section
[Music]
they add planks to both sides of the
bottom section to gradually build up the
curved side walls
[Music]
the side walls meet at the top on either
side
of a central plank that's pre-wired with
the sauna's led ceiling lights
workers strap three galvanized steel
cables around the sides
and pull them to a specific tension
[Music]
these cables further bind the planks to
each other
[Music]
the structural assembly is now complete
they begin
installing the interior components
starting with the thermometer
and hydrometer
next they mount a pivoting cover over
the fresh air vent holes
this allows users to block outside air
or allow it in
then they add an hourglass that counts
down 15 minutes
the recommended time to spend in a sauna
next comes the electric stove it
contains volcanic rocks that absorb and
store the heat
you have the option of pouring water
onto the hot rocks to create steam
after installing benches and a water
absorbent rubber floor
they hang the door the glass in both the
door and rear window
is tinted for privacy the sauna reaches
a temperature
of 185 degrees the barrel shape of the
sauna
optimizes the circulation of the heat
and steam